hi I'm Michele and the first time I saw
a porn was he's convincing her to oh not
that long ago today I'm gonna be
spending the day with a porn star what
intrigues me a lot about the adult film
industry and porn stars in general is
that their line of work is sharing
something that is so private yet their
normal life is completely unknown to the
public so I'm really interested to see
what is actually her private life hi
welcome to my little my little cottage
the ukuleles I have seven of them these
are two of them this one is Vinny he's a
concert sized uke and that one's chips
which is an acoustic electric that I've
been recommending for of five six years
Wow yeah Mia is really really kindly
offered to take me
but make sure you're safe okay me part
I've been an adult film for almost three
years how did you get started well I
have always been a very sexual person
and at that point of my life I was
exploring being clear and polyamory and
open relationships and swinging and
someone can set off hand I think you
should do porn so I went on Craigslist
of all things I was like okay I'm gonna
get a feel for this and then and see
what I can do and make decisions based
on that I felt like I was in the career
that was meant for me it felt like the
community that I've been waiting for
that super sex positive and mindful and
smart okay so we are here in San Diego
about to Boulder this rock which means
we're rock climbing without ropes there
are definitely things you learn like
opening up to the camera
finding your light making sure your hair
isn't covering your face while you're
sucking [ __ ] are you ever like
self-conscious on camera absolutely but
I tried not to focus on that when I am
on so you go over this way what was it
like telling your friends and family
that you reduce or do they not know my
community in San Diego I'm Alec for life
family members you know definitely a
hard thing to talk about with my family
because we I had no sexual education
from my parents other then don't do it
I'm from a really conservative town very
religious do you know what do you watch
to watch porn now I mean sometimes I
[Applause]
feel like I grew up and I obviously knew
masturbation was but I just thought it
was a thing that guys did and like hot I
just thought like wow like I've been
relying on guys do this for so many
years
and now I don't feel like that's right I
have to have that and that was really
empowering you got it hey do you want a
picture of that have you ever felt
uncomfortable during a scene certainly
and that's my safe words are in place to
make sure that line of communication
open to make sure that those
uncomfortable moments are just moments
of adjustment and not necessarily
something from a malicious place
horrible people do exist the majority of
the people in the industry and the
people that I have encountered are there
because we love our profession and we
respect each other well enough to
understand everything about consent and
make sure that all the acts that we do
are consented by and that we're having a
good time because that's what makes good
content there you go this is where you
can this is one little place is that one
of them yeah can you show like sometimes
me how to do this okay if I were to
pretend that's the webcam right okay
I'll pose my body so I can show like in
the skin and like look really curvy like
because I have those sometimes and like
prop myself up on my elbow or if I want
I can like tighten the frame so it's
like from my hips up and I can sit
comfortably like this for a longer
period of time I like laughs slap hugs
and glass toys because you can make them
really cold what is this a butt plug oh
this is really fun because if the tail
is out I can like tug on the tail like
stimulate my butthole my butt have stuff
in my mouth I've like butt plug fur
that's the danger of your favorite this
guy I love that one's a prettiest have
you ever like faked orgasm orgasms yeah
yeah cuz not everything some some people
are like I want this place super hard at
this speed faster harder in five seconds
come for me right now I'm like okay this
person doesn't know how orgasms work and
they're just like making a lot of
demands I like set my boundaries cuz
that's what sex work is all about
setting your boundaries and singing to
me like this is about me sweetie
what's your female performance do when
they get their period for work makeup
sponges
what is that so you know the thing
that's squishy that you used to apply
foundation on your face shove that up
your cooter so I want to know what is
the greatest number of times you've
orgasm in a day 26 in an hour and then I
didn't count the rest because it was
like a challenge by a camp member
idigturkey
in your mouth it was rather big and
veiny I was surprised and kind of nod
you did cry the first time we had sex I
said don't you worry you look like your
hands are full just kidding come out